I know people this is the last Ruben
report of 2014 i'm dave rubin and i have
an incredibly esteemed panel with me we
have the Yoda of the tyt network stevo
and the jar jar binks a light I almost
said Chewbacca but I can we can we meet
halfway and call me walk we have the EOS
horrible the Ewok rebel leader Malcolm
pleasure we've got a lot to get to so
let's get right to it so the year is
ending in case you didn't know that yeah
we only got a couple hours left and
gallop did a poll on the most admired
men of 2014 so let's take a look alright
a lot of political people here Barack
Obama number one Pope Francis number to
Bill Clinton billy graham george w bush
ben Carson I thought that one was kind
of interesting Stephen Hawking Bill
Gates Bill O'Reilly Benjamin and Yahoo
and we were going to put just leave it
at 10 but then 11 snuck in Vladimir
Putin so that one so let's start with
with Putin I kind of think this is a
little like there's people that actually
respect what a nut bag he is like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything he's
a people dress on Fox they talk about
how they like Putin a lot I mean not you
know what just a boat took to contrast
him with Barack Obama who's such a big
wussy but potent a strong man they
admire that I mean they're simple minded
they appreciate an authority figure who
is authoritative and that he gives him
that yeah it definitely matter what the
policies are that appeals to all of our
it right about Putin right he's strong
he's a little bit crazy and he is this
philosophy I see I like I take just
takes yeah and he just takes he just
takes it right he took Robert Kraft
Super Bowl ring he took Crimea yeah and
I heard that he took some oligarchs
house on the on the outside of London he
took Robert Kraft Super Bowl ring he's
that yeah how did you do that well
Robert Kraft was it was in Russia
visiting and Putin saw his ring is like
I like your ring he's like yeah this is
my super boring take a look at it it was
yeah I like it I just took it and Robert
cross is like uh can I have that back
yeah and one of the security guys were
like
this is your gift to mr. Putin wow so
Putin has a super bowl yeah that is
something yeah that is something yeah so
I agree it is the kind of let's go back
to list for just a second there so Obama
number one you know look I certain
people so Obama number one Francis
number two those are the you know those
are the big the big shots what do you
like they're welcome Billy Graham yeah
it's like I mean he's hanging on it's
good for him he's been apparently in the
top ten off and on for the past 75 years
yeah and I'm wondering like are these
are they going back to the same people
every year because nobody under 85 is
saying Billy Graham or even knows who
Billy Graham is but that he keeps making
it on the list is admirable in some ways
i right so a lot of its just name
recognition obviously because you're
just picking name what do you think of
george w bush i know you're a big fan of
george w bush and all his policies so
this list is odd I mean this is gal I
mean this is the gallery look I get it
it's a see famous people right i mean
you know the guy who does some great
work in your local neighborhood he won't
be on this list I get it but how is
George Bush even relevant anymore he's
been out of office for eight years or
six years like what to admire about him
at this it's not it's what it really is
a llama it's no no it's an open-ended
question where they don't give you a
list of possibilities they make you come
up with it yourself and the average
American it's not the most admired list
it's more like name somebody famous
besides Kim Kardashian because you know
you can't say her so it's like oh and a
lot of people probably still think
George Bush is president I mean they're
not they're right you know they're not
narrowing down the field that not only
of the people you can select but the
people they're asking that's really sad
that is said so to that point though
what why is it that we admire
politicians after being in the news biz
for a year and a half or two years now I
have so little regard for politicians
never think they're telling the truth
all the stuff that we all know but why
do people still so it's just the
recognition I getting it is a bowl like
this but in general why do people think
the politicians I something I don't
think we I think we attribute to
politicians and to our leaders the
qualities that we wish they had right
because we want to believe that they are
leading us and that we want to be
optimistic about our future and our
present state so we attribute these
qualities to them that we wish all
leaders had and
is why in every fictional account of
anything whether it's religion or it's a
Hollywood movie they have they possess
these unbelievable human traits of
strength and integrity and all that that
in real life isn't is rarely displayed
right in real life they're getting
[ __ ] in bathrooms and what else are
they doing well I got nuts that's
something I could admire wait a minute
on that note gallup also did the 2014
most admired woman's let's take a look
at that list Hillary Clinton number one
are we having Hillary fatigue at Oprah
Winfrey Malala condi rice Michelle Obama
Angelina Jolie sarah palin Princess Kate
Elizabeth Warren Laura Bush so again
very political heavy I mean this is yeah
sattar than the men's lives all right
yeah and it's because I guess there are
more men who are famous for being I
don't know I mean not a Kim Kardashian
type but more of substance but Laura but
Laura Bush right so George Bush was on
the other one but Laura Bush and so lord
was crazy so can you think of anything
she did she wanted kids to read right
wasn't that her thing it did do we have
any proof that the literacy rates went
up or that she actually did anything
even while she was there much less six
years later I don't think there's a lot
of people investing time and effort to
follow up on Laura Bush to make sure
that she wasn't you know yeah I think
she was show a bomb on that list yeah
there are three there are three africa
three black women on this list which i
think is pretty pretty impressive uh and
uh what do you guys make of Hillary
because to me it's like everyone is so
over her already every time I read an
article about her you can actually see
it now the media is starting to turn on
her but they're gonna come back we have
so much time that's that's that's we're
living in our political bubble most
people don't pay any attention on any of
this [ __ ] yeah they don't know they
don't think they're still don't know
that she was Secretary of State they may
think she already is president yeah I
mean you know that with all the most
people are not so that's they're just
asking name someone famous until they
come back Hillary has a lot of mind
share in the sense that she's been
around for a long time yeah and um and
the fact that she's number one on this
list I mean I get it I mean just like
Obama be number one on the other list
right they're just the most widely
recognized people and Hillary is known
for being smart
I mean everyone everyone thinks she's
smart and no one thinks she's dumb even
if you hate her you think she's smart
and that she's accomplished so I I get
it okay I mean that's a much more
reasonable thing to have on the list
then let's say Laura Bush but even condi
rice I mean why is she on this list for
2014 issues on the list you know six
years ago I get it but right now it just
tells you how how outdated everything is
and that the you know once she become
famous for any reason whatsoever whether
you're in politics or movies or whatever
it is you're just on this list forever
so if they did so next year con tu
recipe on this list next right nine to
10 of those games you're gonna be the
same one so I guess the one that that I
know you guys are gonna be happy about
so Elizabeth Warren being on there
that's actually a sign of something
right because the one you know who else
who isn't with number three hello oh I
know the people who say Malala those are
ones i give credit to that's impressive
they know Malala I mean I mean I kind of
get pissed off cuz she's like done more
at 16 than I will ever accomplished in
my entire life but nevertheless those
are people that know yeah I made it on
the route report yeah and so but that
gives me a little bit of hope I didn't
really see any hope really on the the
men's list yeah ben Carson Billy Graham
uh but but Malala that's great I admire
that yeah I am I admired that actually
shocked that she still hide the list
right III love it I but yeah the other
one on the list that's absurd is what's
with angelina jolie and and Princess
Kate right well again that's just purely
what you're saying about name name
recognition jolina Jolie has a
reputation as being a real humanitarian
yeah it's a lot of time in babies
adopted half of the orphans in Africa
and that's something yeah right and she
got that double mastectomy and she's a
spokesperson for for cancer and yes and
she's a humanitarian but still it's not
like saying Jennifer Aniston not to take
in any way from Jennifer Aniston but
yeah she did not over the Brad Pitt
inbred pouch internet did take very good
weight so last night is just getting
back to is on for a second um do you
think she has any realistic chance in
2016 do you think there's any chance
that they yeah you really think I i
think i think there's all she's gonna be
like the howard dean like she'll get
everybody really excited and then
something will happen that'll just it'll
just kind of disappear no i think well
you wall she has a lot of
grassroots support and you know it's
interesting what it'll be interesting to
see how the establishment reacts to that
right because her biggest threat is
actually not even the Republicans is to
stop this establishment Democrats right
they're gonna they're gonna destroy her
yeah so Clinton and that whole machinery
will come after her if she decides to
run so it's really her decision as to
whether she wants to fight that battle
vs. the Clintons and perhaps be a cold
outcast in the Democratic Party
establishment or whether she wants to
fight that and be a champion of the
people I hope she chooses the ladder
we'll see ya we shall see all right
let's move on the 2014 consumer
satisfaction index came out where they
ranked how people feel about certain
companies and the value of their
services and believe it or not you know
what two companies people hate the most
yeah Time Warner and Comcast and of
course Time Warner and Comcast are
actually merging to become one more evil
corporation so I thought to start here I
know that you hate time warner you've
gone on Twitter rants about time warner
so let's just start with Time Warner
yeah this is when i wish corporations
were in fact people so i could kill them
so they're not people yeah that i would
like to murder time warner okay I would
it is such a bad company in terms of
service their lack of respect for the
customers and the way they treat people
I mean in fact it to stay at your house
all day you did like take a day off from
work yeah literally all day I am 25 p.m.
yeah we're then dealing a [ __ ] show
up and I was so angry auntie burner say
well why do you Time Warner you should
detach from from it's not for my
television right kit for my internet
yeah I need internet access and where I
live in LA they are literally the only
choice I have there is no other choice
yeah even want to pay fifty thousand
dollars I can't get another choice this
is it yeah so the fact that cable
companies are not treated as as a
utility is insanity they should be
deemed the utility and we move on
because there's no way you can compete
against time work I mean the idea of a
free mark is that you know if dave rubin
opens about indian restaurant and and
then Malcolm opens one up
I open one up the one that had love in
the impression for the record right all
right but you know the one that does the
best is presumably the one that has the
best food for the best price well you
don't have that kind of competition
there is no such free market for a
massive utility like the water company
Electric Company and the cable company
and pretending the cable companies are
not a utility is this ridiculous right
so to your point now Time Warner is
actually merging with comcast that makes
it a lot worse well I think it's sort of
like when you have a two people like a
couple and they fight all the time and
they're both obnoxious and you know they
never get along and it's awful and
they're like you know what all that
we're gonna going to solve all this by
getting married we'll get married and
that's we got with with Comcast and Time
Warner's that the question is will they
be as awful as time warner or as awful
as comcast but but you know they're
gonna be actually even work yeah yeah
but your point is about the monopoly is
what is their incentive to provide good
customer service oh and in the article
you you know that your producer
forwarded to us as they mention that
Comcast they're making some steps one of
the things they're doing is they hired
someone to come in and teach them how
not to constantly [ __ ] over your
customers like I mean I'm just wondering
looking at that meeting of the guys got
you know he's doing a slide show for I
was like okay so when the customer calls
you're gonna want to pick up that phone
yeah we don't just keep running that
loop of your your call is important to
us please stay holding on the line over
and over again you don't want someone on
the other end to actress actually and
then when they express what their
problem is you you're gonna want to try
to solve that problem yeah I know you
know the executive steverson no wait
wait what do you say the but it's all
was that was that work wait can you just
explain to me why is it that every time
you call these guys you have to punch in
your phone number right you have to
actually like tap it you know yes the
buttons to get it in and then the second
they get on the phone with you they ask
for your phone number again why is that
if I met me steve-o there's no
explanation um I i I'm amazed when I
call some 800 number or some customer
service number and a human says hello
it's incredible I'm like what are you a
real person yeah oh you may start
sounding like robots action yeah it's
really amazing so uh back to the merger
is yeah this is a real problem because
there's already like regional monopolies
by these cable companies but now they
want to create a national monopoly and
they've hired 40 lobbying firms not 40
human beings are 40 different lobbying
firms to push all the Congress people
and all the influencers in Washington to
approve this deal if this is not a
monopoly than what is he wanted to say
it's a Steve's point I think is that
their job creators and that this murder
is creating a lot of work right so if we
allow this merchants to go through we
should just take all of our laws against
monopolies and just just just throw them
away which was pretty much done already
but so is this one of the things were
Obama what kind of failed here because
you know he said he was for net
neutrality but then he appointed a guy
that was the head to the head of the FCC
who worked who was a lobbyist for the
telecom industry and then just a couple
weeks ago I think it was the day after
the election he again double down and
said I'm for net neutrality but at the
same time he's appointing people that
are not so we have these companies
coming together and to me the bigger
risks still is net neutrality which the
jury is out on which could really screw
us yeah that's not even a question thank
you for that encouraging note of
optimism for the new year day yeah okay
give me some hope I mean get her there's
no hope for the online people real
there's no hope net neutrality is gone
it's gonna be gone I mean it's just a
matter of time and I had how they couch
it it's gonna be gone all right well I
wish we could have ended that one is
slightly more inspirational give me
something here Malcolm something
slightly more well you know what you're
watching this now and they haven't taken
it down have they and what we are
recording it on December 31st console
right down below you guys know about the
Middle East it's like middle earth but
more violent so Hamas which is in charge
of the Gaza Strip they were gonna have a
little peace thing the Israelis and the
Palestinians were going to get together
send 37 kids from Gaza to Israel to the
west bank they were going to go to a zoo
I think in Jerusalem and it was just
going to be a little thing for kids to
get together and talk and see other
people etc etc of course Hamas not that
into it we've got a quote from their
spokesman Hamas spokesman a odd bazoom
said the decision was made to protect
the culture of our children and our
people from normalizing relations with
Israel
he said Hamas would make sure a trip
will never happen again all right so I
don't want to get into a big debate
about the Middle East let's not do that
right this second but what I thought was
interesting about this is first of it
doesn't these type of stories don't get
much play we only talk about it when
there's bombing and things like that but
isn't this kind of stuff more important
because all the leaders now we're going
to die off eventually right 20 30 years
they're all going to be gone it's the
next generation that has to have some
feeling of peace so if we can't even get
kids to go to a zoo together I guess my
question is is the Middle East just
perpetually screwed well I want to say
thank you for bringing up this topic
because my one of my new year's
resolutions for 2014 was to solve the
israeli-palestinian crisis and summer
31st so I gotta get to it let's get to
UM and I think no I you know in some
ways I think this is encouraging because
they're even doing this oh you're not
doing well no there's the effort to
attempt to do it and that if initially
there was approval from whoever there
the neo from Hamas to allow this happen
and then it got rejected when they of it
so what I think that points out to me is
something that most people don't
acknowledge about Hamas which is that
like any political party there are more
moderate elements and I mean we like to
think of home house we think they're all
just death to Israel you know that's
just the there they all have that you
know tattooed on their arm sling but
like any political part is that there is
there are modern more moderates and
there you know there's a there some who
obviously when this was initially
approved you thought this was a good
idea they lost this battle but at least
it indicates that there are people
within Hamas or in the West bet I mean
in Gaza who want to promote person a
person connections between the people of
the children of Gaza and children of
Israel so while this one it's
disappointing oh and and you know sort
of plays into the idea that Hamas is
totally unwilling to deep into the most
moderate thing or oil which is let kids
go to go to a zoo um I think that this
is your right is what's going to have to
happen and is going to be the next
generation and if unfortunately if the
hardliners win then these things don't
happen but if more moderate elements can
be encouraged and promoted on both sides
but that's okay I think that's the
important
part the both sides part so you know
I've read that younger Israelis are more
hardline than lot of their parents are
and that's largely because they grew up
with this complete divide where they
didn't have any interaction with the
other side whereas the older generation
even though they were fighting for much
of the past 20 30 40 years they did have
some normalize relations and they
realize they're not all so bad and there
can be a better way whereas if you grow
up only seeing them as enemies and and
never having any normal interactions
with them harden your stance so I think
these kind of trips are very important
but I think that not just Hamas kids I
mean I'm Palestinians chillin should go
to Israel and see that people in Ezra
are totally fine and normal and they're
not evil people that we need to kill and
throw into the ocean I think Israeli
children should go to come to Gaza and
see how the Palestinians live and
realize wow they are living under some
really really bad conditions this isn't
right we need to fix this too right but
they'd be killed or kidnapped if they
went i guess i get i get what youre my
findings like a philosophical we have
clearance which parent volunteer for
that one right like you're not gonna
send your kid and they there what they
were there and you know anything so but
i get your the over right right right
not there are massive logistical
realities i have you worked out you want
to send one kid in a bulletproof bubble
and have him float over the place i
guess i'm seinfeld bubble sentiment yeah
but yeah I I do think that that any kind
of real long-term solution to any kind
of situation like that has to be with
with with the younger generation
completely seeing and wanting that
change and accepting embracing it and
and at some point struggling for that
right so totally on board that part of
it so shouldn't this be the type of
thing you know they're signing all these
papers the UN thing just yesterday got
defeated at the Security Council their
Palestinians are going to icc they all
these paper it's just a lot of paperwork
and adults fighting about [ __ ] but
shouldn't this be the type of thing that
people actually
rally around like that to me like this
is so basic like and if they can't even
do this the idea that they call it a
peace process is really just because
both words have a letter P in it right
like if they can't get kids together
then what real hope is there but yeah
what's the glimmer of hope that you can
take look so so I mean as Malcolm
correctly pointed out this trip was at
some point approved by Hamas and for
whatever reasons they unapproved or
disapproved it and and look III don't
understand the motivations behind it and
you know I would love to get someone
from Hamas explain why they think casa
this is a good idea yeah I think they
would argue that it's a propaganda you
know that's you know yeah of course
maybe it is I don't I don't know okay so
for whatever reason they decide to not
do it but I'm a little reluctant to just
isolate one incident and cast blame on
one side or the other because this
situation has so many layers yes so much
history and so many instances were each
side can rightfully claim that they were
victims of massive injustice that
there's often overreaction right so it
gets really really don't want to make a
segment about the whole freaking thing
this was really just like about kids and
if we can't get these freaking kids
together then I don't know what what
hope we have but you know who's so you
want just another another note of
optimism for the new year you that's why
you wanted to cover this reality TV if
you've been watching the show you know
that I hate it and I've got a little
good news for you it is starting to
crumble yeah that's right according to
LA Times ratings for reality TV you're
totally in the toilet and we've got a
couple examples for you Fox lost 50
million dollars on utopia did either one
of you guys see utopia by any chance it
was a disaster was on for about three
weeks about a bunch of people they tried
to create a futuristic civilization
together is terrible NBC's The Voice
which was pretty big for a couple
seasons so it's season finale dropped
nearly ten percent this month duck
dynasty that's a show with it's a bunch
of Hick's that [ __ ] ducks or something
that's not like a sound like that the
ratings have plunged TLC cancelled here
comes honey boo boo
now apparently that wasn't totally prism
ratings but I guess Boo Boo's mom had
sex with her brother or something no
something close to that I ex-offender
she was a sex offender yeah close enough
and AMC largely abandoned a three-year
foray into unscripted programming so I
think these are all good signs because
reality TV is just awful and we've been
bludgeoned to death with Kardashians and
all this just awful housewife nonsense
as media guys this has got to feel
pretty good right well one thing that I
find interesting about the the articles
that talk about how the networks in
general are losing their audience to
cable and one cable doesn't do reality
as much as the networks do but it and
it's true of course the networks are
declining and they don't have the market
show that they had before and american
idol is another one that is declining
yeah but they always talk about as if
it's a zero-sum game between the cable
you know cable viewers and network
viewers and then they might talk about
Netflix and the new new Amazon coming
out with their own show the programming
but nobody ever talked about YouTube
which I feel like that's where they're
losing a lot of their viewership is to
YouTube like you people right yeah you
good people and if there's there's not
an acknowledgment it's like there
there's only in that's because they
don't they don't live in the world of
young people yeah who I mean it used to
be when you're a teenager for a lot of
people you come home from school you
throw it on your backpack and turn on TV
and watch TV now those kids go up to the
room and turn on YouTube and so where
they factor in it right so to that point
so let's just stick on that for a sec
before we go back to reality TV to that
point is this also just like a
generational thing sort of like we were
talking about in the previous segment on
the Middle East that all the people that
are in the business that controlled the
money they did grow up throw in their
backpack watching TV after school etc
etc so those are the adults now
controlling the money versus YouTube
almost anyone under 40 at this point
gets almost everything online so there's
a big disconnect between the decision
makers in programming and media and the
people who are the consumers of that
media and I mean I give them a little
bit more credit because they don't say
the word you too but they do mention how
they're losing audiences to the internet
which we talking about like Netflix and
they don't
they don't acknowledge YouTube s because
like there are shows on YouTube and
there are people who subscribe I don't
think they even understand right i guess
that is that's the mole that's the thing
that YouTube hasn't crossed yet like
there there isn't the breakout sort of
orange is the new black or transparent
or something like that so I guess that's
what I probably would hate you tube is
working on that right now yeah yeah so
back to the issue of reality shows yeah
I think there's a I think there's two
basic types so one is like the game show
essentially right so like American Idol
even survivor those are kind of game
show contest yeah contest of some sort
and I think there's always always a
market for that because people want to
see that and that's actually reality and
of course there's also some some editing
that that goes into it to give it some
flavor so certain contestants are more
likable than others yeah so we get that
but there but that's gonna be there the
other kind of reality program is just a
pure voyeuristic type so so we want to
peek into the Real Housewives want to
peek into duck dynasty honey boo boo and
a lot of it is just a just a spectacle
watching you would we want to see
something that's [ __ ] up and yeah and
you know extreme from one from one to
the other range of normal behavior right
that to me is gonna die and mate and
that namely because the novelty has worn
off and it's not even reality it's
completely fake it's also more quickly
yeah it's essentially scripted but it's
just cheaper and with with less likeable
characters I think and so I think that's
gonna be way way scaled back so that
actually might be something that YouTube
actually hastened the death of because
once they put webcams in people's rooms
you could actually see reality yeah so
it sort of made the reality of the
because it's all scripted yeah the
unscripted nonsense but I think you make
good point about sort of the game show
aspect verse whatever because to me you
are watch reality TV I could turn on the
price is right at any time and it's
always entertaining I mean I haven't
watched it and God knows how long but
you could always turn it on for five
minutes and something sort of fun is
happening and you're seeing real people
and there's something actually and it's
not about that voyeuristic [ __ ]
right and we all I mean look we all love
watching people win stuff
right so like a half time of a
basketball game in a guy makes a
half-court shot and he wins $50,000 who
doesn't let the place goes nuts in the
arena and on television you know
halftime of bowl games that they have
scholarships that people win from
throwing footballs or catching footballs
so we love that stuff we love it and
there's always a market for that right
we love ya you will react yeah that's
what you're saying yeah yeah well that's
like my question is that people are
people becoming more savvy I don't like
to give the American public any credit
yes you can check from the back to the
earlier segment about the who we admire
but I wonder if people are beginning to
say you know they see the ad for the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians like oh
you know Kim and her mother getting a
big fight over who's gonna you know and
we know that that is totally phony and
made up and they just completely
manufactured for our benefit and you
know how many times can we watch Real
Housewives rip out fake hair extensions
you know I mean in getting these
terrible fights like we've literally
they went from ripping out hair
extensions ripping off a leg did you see
that there was an episode of one of them
Beverly Hills or something where a woman
actually ripped her prosthetic leg off
and threw it at somebody so that made us
a moment ago here you have a bit Mona
jumped the shark without a leg but wait
all right so final so my question is
potentially we are just wising up that
this isn't reality yeah and it's and if
you want to watch scripted shows there's
much better scripted shows than keeping
up with the kardashians on netflix or on
amazon or somewhere else yeah and you
know we're on AMC or but mostly not on
the network's but not on the network so
that that basically is my final point
that the there is actually good TV now
so is that the other thing that maybe
that's right through this horrible
10-year span that we went through this
that television actually did make a
comeback no I think television is at its
finest in his history I think there are
more good shows on television now than
ever before and and it shows maybe from
from HBO but like Game of Thrones
boardwalk empire you know these are
outstanding shows and and even shows
like the I don't watch but walking dead
is very popular Breaking Bad
mad men there's so many good shows on
television that's available both on TV
and also on netflix and hulu you watch
that you don't watch this [ __ ] honey
boo boo nonsense you know steve is by
the way paying spokesman for AMC and HBO
everybody yeah let you know baby please
yeah on your behalf but watch this watch
this Malcolm's have paid spokesmen for
the reuben report so tell them what they
should do when they're done watching
this it should drive down down there and
look at this and then you know like like
like like like and comment below that's
right so there is a fantastic new
company called skip lagged and of course
they are being sued by the big boys
orbits and united and why are they being
sued what's they look so what skip lag
does is they find cheap one-way fares by
surfacing weird airline pricing
strategies like pricing in New York to
San Francisco Lake Tahoe flight cheaper
than in New York to San Francisco flight
so you booked all the way through to
tahoe debark at san francisco and walk
away from the final leg okay so this is
pretty great we've done a bunch of
stories on these new types of companies
that are doing things a little bit
differently away from the big boys like
Tesla Airbnb uber things that people
love and then of course the lobbyists
and the big company sue them and fight
with them and all that stuff so this is
pretty great and it was done by a 22
year old kid he created this thing he's
now being sued for seventy-five thousand
dollars let's take a look at the lawsuit
so in the lawsuit United in orbits
called skip leg unfair competition and
alleged that it's promoting strictly
prohibited travel they want to recoup
75,000 lost revenue okay so the the
75,000 is nothing but this is just the
worst of the worst this is somebody
figuring out something cool I mean it's
exactly what's happening with uber and
Tesla and air B&B in all these cities
somebody figuring out a way around the
system to help the marketplace help the
common person what happens the big boys
come in yeah give me something make me
feel full I want to I want to change my
vote to make this guy the most admired
man of the year
he's my hero forget the route that you
might fly every firefighters or Ebola
doctors or whatever no no yeah this guy
is my hero for taking down the airlines
and I love that you know their idea you
know what we gotta do we gotta quell
that's gotta quash it you know before it
gets too big so we'll sue him and then
there'll be news stories about it
everywhere they'll be talking about it
on the internet and we're gonna mean his
site is down now if you can't keep up
with all the traffic so genius I mean
right okay so let's just talk about the
lawsuit for a second because that's
that's the stupidest part so let's just
get it out of the way as a former lawyer
so 75 grand they're suing him for
nothing just to scare him right that's
just a scarran but it but in actuality
they're doing exactly what say what I
hadn't heard about this until you
someone for unfair competition that's
just a bit ly catch-all phrase yeah just
say like I don't like what you're doing
I'm gonna sue you for there's no
specific cause I'm just gonna sue you
right and unfair competition is very
broad so you can't get thrown out of
court so it could go to trial and the
problem with gonna try that costs a ton
of money there's no there's no way this
kid can possibly afford going to trial
fighting us in winning yeah he's
literally a 22 year old you did this in
his apartment in New York but also I
look I'm not a lawyer obviously between
it to say unfair competition he's not
he's not creating a business that's
competing with them he's just creating
sort of a way around here mention he's
just really that's looking the airlines
like how dare you inform our customers
about different pricing strategies that
is outrageous right and but I I've
always wondered about this because you
would you would book a flight you
looking for a flight from New York San
Francisco and you can and then you you
look at another flight that you go into
LA and it goes through San Francisco but
the LA flight is cheaper like what the
hell is going on here and the airline's
I don't know why they are so you know
they want to continue with this sort of
a pricing strategy because I guess there
the idea is we're gonna try it the ideal
situation is you have a full flight
where no two people pay the same amount
that's like the you know the harmonic
convergence for an airline but and if
they have want to come out and explain
to the American public why it's to our
benefit that nobody can know why the
weird other prices come from and how
they come to arrive at them I'd like
them to make that argument in court so
is that what this is really about that
the airline's want to keep us all in
this constant state of having no
idea what a price is ever supposed to be
or how early is about the book or how
they arrive at or anything I just booked
a flight for for April from LA to New
York and I think I got a pretty decent
price but I just kept thinking well what
should I wait longer do I you know like
what's the there is no rhyme or reason
to it right problem the problem is that
airline prices are too cheap okay and
it's too cheap in the sense that
airlines can't make any money they're
losing money all the time so so the good
thing is that they're affordable so most
people can afford to travel right air
maybe not internationally but
domestically they can't the downside is
that you have shitty service and the
workers get paid crap yeah and I need to
make sacrifices constantly and one of
the ways day the airlines make more
money is to gouge people for first-class
tickets we're going to afford to pay it
and to have these weird mysterious
pricing structures but they're not even
that weird or mysterious because it's
really south west southwest that's the
price whatever price they're at right
all other airlines follow it and maybe
hike it up by two dollars or they do
tricky things like yeah we're not going
to you know it's cheaper than Southwest
however we're gonna charge you for for
bringing anything on the airplane or
charging you whatever for for drinks and
a massive change FIFA to change anything
so there's all these little games they
play to make money and they actually
make money on those fees without those
fees they'll be massive in the red so
that's that's part of the problem and
what this kid has done is try to he
lifted that layer so you can see
underneath it and see what's really
happening it can make informed choices
and the airlines they don't want you to
make informed choices because that means
you save money and pay less which means
they even they lose even more money yeah
their margins are very tight obviously
which and the the fact that they you
know if you need to go somewhere this
week and you have to book that late then
they're gonna they're gonna gouge you
and doesn't even do about it because
they all do it so is that why no airline
has ever come out with a flat rate thing
you know that they're just flat rate to
these cities no matter what because I
would love that idea like even if
sometimes you're paying a little bit
more just the idea you don't have to
deal with all the nonsense like a gold
saturn pricing strategy
it's like instead of or buses right if
you want take a bus from here to Las
Vegas it's the same price yeah I mean
it's posted you don't have to do a
search for that particular day it just
posted right so do we need we need an
Airbnb or uber of airlines right like is
that the only way to ever sort of fix
this or get it to a more sensible rate I
don't know who's gonna be fine these
things got a lot of people there aren't
as many player plane owners as car
owners I suppose yeah but somebody I
want my air travel to be regulated and
safe and I want you know how much the
guy with the plane at the other corner
of the block we don't want that guy all
right I don't know what do you guys
think I like the idea you're at the
airport and you're like is this my plan
is this huh mean what do you think do
what can we do to get airline prices
down subscribe a comment down below want
to get married but don't have a
significant other well you are in luck
because in Kyoto Japan a new company
called circa travel is offering solo
weddings yeah that's right we've got
some more info for you Japanese
luxurious wedding kimono or dress you
can have an on-location photo shoot and
an entire experience tour here's what it
says on the website you are single and
you don't know if you were able to get
married and have a wedding ceremony in
the near future but you would like to
have some new pictures of yourself in a
wedding gown or in a gorgeous bridal
kimono now when you are young and
beautiful Steve I can see this is for
you or you even believe that you don't
really have to get engaged to be able to
wear a bridal outfit or you're already
married but didn't have a proper
ceremony with a beautiful dress and find
this back to be quite regretful or you
did wear a dress but it was so long ago
that you would like to experience it
again or you were too busy with the
wedding preparations to enjoy yourself
fully during the special day and you're
looking for a second chance offer
yourself an opportunity to experience
the feeling of being a princess in the
beautiful and charming city of Kyoto
okay so just to be very clear you're not
actually marrying or so it's not
actually a solo wedding but you get to
experience it either again or you it's
like a redo or a first time if you don't
have somebody yet you look in your young
good so you don't even have a ceremony
there
yeah you just get dolled up and you get
all these pictures taken and you go
through the motions that a bride will go
through we right before the wedding with
all the pictures are that and then you
can have a nice keepsake look how
beautiful i looked in this outfit and
Here I am so I i love it i think the
great great idea yeah what do you think
this appeals to the most the girl thats
a 22 and she's like I'm young and I look
good now and I want these pictures now
but I don't have a boyfriend or does it
appeal more to the one that like it all
went wrong you know I say that it all
went wrong but the reality i find this
interesting cuz it's like uh it's a real
modern take on wedding it's like it's
like wedding cosplay you know and so but
when you're actually getting married the
the bride is usually fighting with her
mother and its traditional marriage and
you know fighting with your mother the
flowers aren't right she's screaming at
the caterer and so no sword they eating
charge everyone yeah oh the seating
chart yeah and and so you can't really
enjoy it I mean some people do but you
but it's difficult to and if also the
groom the groom does nothing but ruin
weddings mean the room is you know it's
just if the best I ideally the groom is
just there doesn't say much and then but
often he's like really hung over from
the bachelor party or his degenerate
friends are they're ruining it or
whatever so the groom is a real
hindrance to a good marriage a good
wedding and so anything and a good match
so I think you know she's these are
women who are trying to isolate all the
best things about a wedding and cut out
all the fat and the unpleasant nice I
think you're overanalyzing I think is
just it well first of all costs
twenty-five hundred dollars so it's not
super cheap right but it's also way
cheaper than an actual wedding I just
think it's it's for people who have the
money to have a fun experience I think
that's all it is so so whether you've
had a good wedding or bad wedding
whatever it is you want to get dolled up
and you know feel special and take all
these great pictures and there are
versions of this in the US in a sense
that you can get glammed up yeah and
they take pictures of here right so the
glamour shots is a much scaled-down
version but it's similar yeah and I
think it I think it peels more to an
older woman who wants maybe kind of you
know relive
you know our past or redo it in some way
I think four or you know maybe a young
girl who wants to just kind of see what
it would feel like but but Malcolm is
right in the sense that a real wedding
even when everything does does go right
right it's still stressful I mean
because you have to make sure that all
your guests are happy there was having a
good time and something always gets
screwed up I get always the flowers and
i right the food is wrong piece is
something something was wrong so it's
stressful ed and and you know at my
wedding everything went pretty much
according to plan and I'm not a
stressed-out person I don't really care
about the same time I was excited in
order to this nervous energy it was it
was so I could barely eat and I remember
everyone telling me you know how good
the food was at my wedding I was like I
don't recall at all yeah and then like
six months later my my parents threw me
a in a second reception in New Jersey
for people can make as California and
that one I was so relaxed I ate like a
pig I got drunk I danced more it was
great yeah and there's something
liberating about it not being the real
thing but kind of a real thing right so
people put so much pressure on
themselves for the weddings and
everything so I get it that this isn't a
real wedding but couldn't you see this
being the next step in lawyer what
happens in America so okay so gays are
gonna get married fine everything's
gonna be fine i know i know it freaks
you people out but it's gonna happen you
know it's ruining our marriage because
you guys got no damage i've already done
to your personal relationships um but i
really could see this becoming something
in America people marrying themselves
people that say I don't want to get
married I don't believe in the
institution of marriage I don't I don't
have a significant other but I want the
[ __ ] cuz so much of its about the [ __ ]
you want the cookware and the knives and
all that other stuff if you will if you
if you have a lot of fun because your
wife's using it to feed you you just
don't see it if you have a lot of
friends who got married and you spent a
lot of money on them and then you're
like hey I want some of it can i come
back to me what I think is really great
about this if it does go the direction
you're talking about is that another
problem that a lot of couples have
traditionally is sort of wedding night
jitters you know like what's going to
happen especially if they have you know
saved themselves for marriage but if
it's just you if it's
just you by choice I have if it's just
you yeah you know I mean cuz your word
you're not gonna be sexually compatible
may be with this person but if it's just
yourself you already know you're gonna
have a gear you're gonna get something
to get something to kind of go nicely
that was a very handy tip all right on
that note I wanna thank Malcolm and
Steve their Twitterers are right down
below I don't forget to Like and
subscribe and what else are the kids
doing out there are commenting then
they're commenting and all that good
stuff and happy new year everybody will
see you next week